[Music]
hey friends and welcome back to the
daily Deni arms any direct ont is dead
two of comic-con which means I've
already scored enough swag that my
Christmas shopping is done alright today
we've got more of what you can expect
from the world of TV this weekend but
first it's time to revive one of my
favourite et YouTube segments ever Jenny
from the block I'm tossing it over to my
man on the street to take you guys
inside the actual convention Jenny
thanks Denny you know they say it every
year but comic-con is madness
so of course I'm throwing myself into
the thick of it all here at the
convention center after that I am a
little bit of a fish out of the water so
pray for me are you guys we get a flex
flex the camera guys out wait no okay
if you blink you might miss them it's
the Platte oh my god dmn there goes my
exclusive so how is this gonna be highly
varied nephew um she never comes to
Christmas so there's that she busy um
you know I get it but you know a
Christmas card oh you know what
something yeah some money do like a
grandma put my nose in the car shooting
me that Holly can we get a stocking
stuffer
[Music]
what are you lady that for ladies at
pool oh my god lady Ryan Reynolds
pleasure to meet you are you excited for
Deadpool - yeah so excited to see my
husband your husband Oh what right
wisely I'm a huge fan and how much work
went into it I'm sorry I'm trying to
keep my eyes up here but nothing too
much salsa I had left town all the
required people come across on you guys
[Music]
don't be fooled by the rocks and I got I
carry our own equipment I am hot you
just fan me real quickly I know it's
Comic Con but I'm still on camera I
already failed I'm not wearing a costume
so you got to start waiting in line for
Hawley's come on you're you're like way
behind
people started waiting and gotta go girl
too much fun now speaking of fun joining
me now is our resident - yes sir -
Leanna you live are you tired so tired
you've already talked to so many people
I hit me with what we can expect the
rest of this weekend it is a massive
year for TV I've got to tell you it's
about 70% TVs 30% movies this year at
comic-con it is crazy
today we have sony big panel the Big
Bang Theory
Game of Thrones and The Walking Dead are
all taking place in Hall H which holds
over 7,000 fan ok now The Walking Dead
they cancelled all other press events
except for this panel in light of the
recent onset passing of their stuntman
now this will also be our first look
footage of season 8 and people are
really excited well you're very excited
about Outlander I am very excited about
Outlander I'm a huge Outlander fan an
outlander panel is today but if you
can't make it tune in to e t--'s
Facebook page for an exclusive interview
with Sam Katrina and more of your
favorite your favorite they're my
favorite and of course we have necklaces
the defender stopping bites when the
most anticipated Marvel shows of the
year there's evolute Cage iron fist and
Jessica Jones all these worlds are
colliding it is going to be epic I
cannot wait for that I will also be
catching up with the strangers things
cast and hoping to get as much scoop for
you guys about season 2 as possible and
you can of course watch those interviews
on et Facebook page on Saturday and all
the CW supers will be stalking me -
stopping by as well arrow the flash
Supergirl
so much do you guys she's busy a lot
going on we caught up on sweet 4 et is a
little packed I like it awesome so
awesome if you guys are in town for the
con Leanne is actually moderating two
really big panels on Saturday Riverdale
and Supergirl so cannot wait I'm self
Senate good luck I knew thank you all
right thank you so much are you guys I'm
not going to lie this is only my second
Comic Con so I'm still a bit of a newb
as you saw on the con floor but someone
who is not Chuck himself Zachary Levi I
chatted with him yesterday about his
11th and very busy comic-con
[Music]
we fuzzball the fact that you came from
d23 now a weekend later you're at
comic-con yeah this is the two
conventions in a row for me but but two
incredible conventions I had never been
a d23 before and I've but I've been to
Disneyland my whole life I grew up in
Southern California I'm a big big nerd
from way back so that was that was super
fun well you're a Disney Prince but I
told you you're quickly becoming a king
of the con especially in this place
looks like a Duke let me say I'm more
like a baron I don't know I've been
super blessed that you know Chuck
introduced me to this world I mean I've
read comment about him play video games
my whole life so this was always my
tribe but I never I was never a
cosplayer I wasn't I'm not really a big
collector so going to conventions wasn't
really my draw but then you know as
Hollywood is want to do it then slowly
takes over everything and so now
Hollywood is everywhere and then Chuck
got to be down here and then he rose and
fuller and you know and then doing nerd
HQ obviously my baby for six years has
definitely given us I don't know like a
really cool place in this community and
I'm really grateful for that even though
we're not doing it this year but I am
hosting flatbeds of comic-con which is
super fun well that you're genuinely a
fan like what do you geek out the most
especially this year at comic-con um no
I mean that the fans I like I think
exclusives and reveals and all that
stuff is super cool but no man I just I
I'm in the business of bringing joy I
hope I hope that I hope that so much of
what this is all even about is that
we're bringing joy to these people who
are the patrons of the Arts who are the
consumers who we only get to do any of
this because they either say I like you
or I like what you do or I'm going to
buy a ticket to your movie or I'm going
to watch your TV show so that's yeah
that's my business like I just I just
want to make people happy I mean you've
been a part of and are part of a lot of
projects that have these huge fandoms
and of course after years of playing
Chuck now you're playing the bad guy in
the site yeah I was over but hey was it
fun for you oh my god it was so much
yeah yeah I mean James III the whole
kind of path was I'm not dule years ago
through like NBC stuff and and we just
got along you know and very kindred
spirits and loved a good dance party and
then so we kind of stayed in touch and
then he was doing
sike and then I started doing nerd HQ
and then he was gracious enough to kind
of rally his troops at site like James
and Steve to come and do panels at HQ
and then I became friends with all of
them and they're just awesome just an
awesome group of people super talented
and and then they were trying to write
me into the show before it actually got
cancelled or you know ended there's a
musical episode I couldn't do that I was
doing toward the dark world in London
and so then they came back to me you
know James I think in like I don't know
like February or March and he hits me up
and says hey are you are you free end of
May beginning of June and I was like for
you my friends anything well not
anything that's James Roday he's a dark
man um just twisted really inside but
anyway so he said hey we're doing a
movie we're doing a psych movie I wanted
lucky to play the bad guy the look is
based on David Bowie's then-white do
gyarah
I'm like dude you had me a bad guy I'm
like I'm so in and they were they really
gave me a lot of trust and a lot of rain
you know to go and explore the space
guys you know I brought a lot of cowbell
to the role and with it and it's super
fun man yesterday there was some sad
news in the music world Linkin Park
frontman Chester Bennington was found
dead of an apparent suicide at the age
of 41 now it's Friday and of course we
usually have a new music Friday for you
guys we thought was only fitting that we
play you out with a little bit of his
recent song heavy between Chiara they
give everything too badly
yeah Drive myself crazy to the chemist
into gravity why is everything so heavy
[Music]
so much more than I can carry right
that's it for us today from comic-con
I'm actually headed back to Los Angeles
to be with you guys on Monday for the
new daily Denny ET will be standing
ground down here at comic-con so stick
with et online.com for all the latest
and of course subscribe to e t--'s
youtube channel and i will see you guys
on Monday
take care have a great weekend